I told you before our vacation last week
that our friend JD Scholten is once
again challenging incumbent disgusting
Republican Steve King in Iowa's fourth
District in 2020 we met JD Schulten down
at Netroots nation in August of 2018 he
ran against JD against Steve King in
2018 and lost by only three points very
sad because it would have been amazing
to knock off one of the most vile and
despicable members of Congress King is
in trouble and JD Shelton is running
King has said crazy things about
abortion King has reminisced about when
white supremacy and white nationalism
weren't offensive saying to the new york
times during an interview white
nationalist white supremacist western
civilization how did that language
become offensive but King is in trouble
Republicans have abandoned him and he
has almost no money this is so funny
King hasn't received one donation from a
PAC associated with an existing member
of Congress this is a common way that
these guys fund each other corporate
packs aren't donating to Steve King
special interest groups aren't donating
to Steve King in the first six months of
this year King received to two donations
from third party political entities one
was from Lamar Smith a Lamar Smith
associated PAC former Republican
congressman and $2,000 from Todd akin
Todd akin is the guy who said that the
body shuts down a legitimate rape and
thus the woman can't get pregnant that
guy is saying I want to donate two
thousand dollars to Steve King
Republican Party groups are also not
donating so this guy can be defeated
think back to 2018
JD Schulten lost by only three points in
2016 I'm sorry in 2018 back when Steve
King was still able to raise money this
guy Steve King is someone who came to
power as a tool of big business quite
frankly he came to power because the
bankers gave him money he came to power
because big builders and companies like
AT&T and big food gave him
money big insurance gave Steve King
money they're not giving him money this
year and that's really really bad for
Steve King so as usual there's the good
and the bad the good news is that
without money he can more easily lose
2jt Schulten the bad or at least the
troubling part is how did it take until
2020 to realize for Republicans that
they need to abandon this guy and the
answer is they don't really care they're
playing now like they're oh they're so
disgusted with the things that Steve
King has said no this is the same Steve
King that's been around all along and
while this wasn't a problem for them
King was another vote in the House and
that's why they wanted it it's not that
he was someone that they disagreed with
or agreed with or whatever they were
indifferent they just want someone to
check a box and say yes I'll vote
Republican now he's become a PR problem
so they're abandoning him let's not
attribute to morality and ethics what we
can attribute merely to Republicans
seeing politics as sport wins and losses
checking boxes and that's it but he
needs to go hopefully he will in 2020
check out JD Shelton's campaign JD's a
former professional baseball player
super nice guy hung out with him in in
2018 in New Orleans as I mentioned he
came so close in 2018 with the loss of
Steve Kings funding and the abandonment
that Steve King is suffering from his
Republican Party colleagues this could
be an amazing time to get a Democrat in
the Iowa 4th congressional district
check it out check out JD Scholten and
hopefully we'll be talking to him on the
program we'll take a quick break after
this we have extraordinarily great
submissions for the David Pakman show
EDM dubstep voicemail remix theme song
if you have no idea what I'm talking
about then I think you're gonna like it
even more